former President George HW Bush is
recovering in a Texas hospital this
morning from another bout with pneumonia
he had a recurrence of the illness that
he battled earlier this year the 92 year
old was admitted for observation on
Friday when he could not get a read when
he could not get rid rather of a
persistent cough Omar Villafranca is at
the Houston Methodist Hospital with the
former president's recent health
struggles Omar good morning good morning
a spokesman for the Bush family says the
former president is in good spirits and
is being held for observation while he
regains his strength a bush family
spokesman says the 41st president had a
mild case of pneumonia which was treated
and has been resolved Bush spent 16 days
in the hospital back in January for
treatment of pneumonia his wife former
first lady barbara Bush was also
hospitalized with bronchitis at the same
time she got better before he did but
refused to leave his side until he was
out of intensive care the last time Bush
41 was seen in public was shortly after
he was released from that last hospital
state he actually did the coin toss at
Super Bowl 50 one which was here in
Houston 10 days ago former President
Bill Clinton tweeted a picture of his
visit with Bush at his home in Houston
where they showed off the socks Clinton
brought as a gift Bush has been known
for his collection of patterned Footwear
now President Bush is the oldest living
president and at this point we do not
have a timetable on when he will be
released Charlie oh my thanks